Once the supreme court upheld the
death pony in 1976 and the three cases,
Greg versus Georgia profit versus
Florida and a jerk versus Texas,
uh,
there were still a number of issues
remaining for the court to decide.
Uh,
one of those was a,
the proportionality,
what crimes to the death penalty,
uh,
applied to,
what about the role of the,
uh,
offender in the crime?
Uh,
the role that a person played
where several people were involved,
uh,
for certain crimes.
Uh,
the,
all of the three cases handled,
uh,
in are decided by the court
in 1976 were murder cases.
Uh,
but what about the death penalty for
cases in which the victim is not killed?
Many of the states which adopted
new death penalty statutes,
particularly Georgia,
uh,
provided for the death pony,
not only for murder,
but for rape,
kidnapping,
uh,
and other offenses.
Uh,
and so the court ultimately decided that,
and then finally,
uh,
for certain offenders,
particularly people who are
mentally disabled and children,
uh,
is the death penalty
excessive or disproportionate,
uh,
for those individuals.
And what we're going to
see in today's class,
as we look through this,
as the court is going to
be counting the states,
how many states have,
uh,
provided,
for,
uh,
whatever the court's considering.
Uh,
is this show that there's a trend or
does it show that there is a consensus
among the states?
Because again,
we're back to what we talked
about where the eighth amendment,
what are the evolving
standards of decency that mark,
uh,
the,
the development of the law.
Uh,
and then we'll also see the court look
at whether or not with each of these
questions,
uh,
the purpose of punishment is served.
And that's a deterrence and retribution.
Uh,
so let's first look at the question
of the role of the offender.
Uh,
in the crime,
uh,
several people are engaged say,
in carrying out a crime,
each person has a different role.
Uh,
one person may be the lookout,
one person may be the
driver of the getaway car.
Uh,
and perhaps there was no intent when
this crime was plan for there to be any
injury to any one or any loss of life.
Uh,
but often unexpected things happen.
The police respond and shots
ring out and someone is killed.
Uh,
and then we assess the,
uh,
role of each person.
Uh,
they're all going to be guilty as
we'll talk about in a moment of murder.
Uh,
but the degree of
culpability may be different.
And so the question is going to be,
are they culpable enough
to be sentenced to death?
And I'd like to talk about two cases,
uh,
where the supreme court decided that
both of these cases involve the felony
murder rule,
which is a rule that just basically says
anyone who commits a felony and the co
or committing a felony in
which a murder is committed,
uh,
that person is guilty of murder,
first degree murder,
regardless of whether he or she committed
or attempted to commit or intended to
commit the murder.
And other words,
going back to my example,
three people are involved.
The person who's the lookout is going
to be just as guilty of murder as the
person who actually fired the
trigger that brought about the death.
But there's obviously different degrees
of culpability between the lookout and
the person who actually pulls the trigger.
Uh,
and of course,
part of that is going to be
based on what the people do.
That was,
what actions did they take.
And part of it is going to be
based on the state of mind.
Uh,
this first came to the court in the
case of Earl Inman versus Florida.
This was the getaway driver,
uh,
in an arm robbery.
Uh,
and the question the court had to decide
was could he be sentenced to death?
He had been sentenced to death.
And the question was,
could he be sentenced to death if
his participation in the crime was,
as the court said,
tangential and he had no attempt,
excuse me,
no intent to kill or for life to be taken.
Uh,
in the case,
the court looks at the different states
and it finds Florida's one of only eight
states that allows the death penalty for
a person who participates in a robbery
where the other robber is the
person who takes the life.
Uh,
they find that of the 739 people who
were under death sentence at the time,
the Inman case was decided only 41,
uh,
where people who had not
actually taken the life.
So again,
the court is looking at what are the
states provide and then they're looking at
what has been the practice even
in the states that allowed this.
Uh,
then the court examines
retribution and deterrence,
uh,
and they decide in this case that
retribution and deterrence is not served a
bill,
cause Edmonds participation,
uh,
was so tangential.
So the court,
uh,
holes that the death
penalty is disproportion,
very close case.
It's a five to four decision justice
white writing for a majority of the court
and Justice O'connor as well.
If she says this,
Berger and Justice Powell and
Justice Rehnquist dissenting,
uh,
the court is now going to look at a
case with a very different set of facts,
uh,
and we're going to see justice white,
move over to the other side.
Uh,
Ricky and Ricky Wayne and Raymond Curtis.
Tyson a broke their father
out of a prison in Arizona.
Uh,
they had a large amount of a weapons,
uh,
in an ice chest,
which they snuck into the prison
and they actually succeeded,
uh,
in this breakout there.
Father Gary Tyson and another prisoner,
uh,
Randy Greenwall,
we're,
uh,
broken out of prison and while
they're trying to make their getaway,
they end up breaking down on the road,
a couple stops to give help.
And it was just a terrible crime.
Uh,
Greenwalt and Gary Tyson,
the father,
uh,
kill,
this couple who had been so nice to stop
and offer them a ride as well as their
children.
So it's a horrendous crime.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the police apprehend
them after a shootout,
but Gary Tyson has died.
He goes out into the desert
and he can't find his way back.
Uh,
he dies of exposure.
So the brothers are,
the people left to be tried.
Greenwald gets the death penalty.
There's no question about his involvement.
But the Garret,
the two brothers are arguing that
they did not intend to kill anyone,
that father and the other fellow had
taken these people away and that they were
walking back to the car.
At the time the shots rang out and they
found out that these people had been
killed and they said also they didn't
cause the death of the victims in this
case.
And as a result of that,
their argument was that while
they were guilty of murder,
they can't be subjected
to the death penalty.
They can be put in prison
for the rest of their life,
but not the death.
Polly,
this time the court looks at the breakout,
looks at the guns involved,
looks at the,
all of the factors in the case and
decides five to four that this the death
penalty can be imposed
against the Tyson brothers.
Uh,
justice O'Connor writes for the court,
uh,
joined by the chief justice as well
as just as white who had written the
previous opinion in
Edmond Powell and Scalia.
Uh,
and the court finds that there
is a consensus among the states,
uh,
that major participation.
Remember that Earl elements
participation was tangential.
Now the court's talking
about major participation,
breaking someone out of prison,
trying to escape with them and a mental
state that the court calls reckless
disregard for human life.
That if you participate
in an activity like this,
you're likely to realize the risk
that there may be human life taken,
uh,
as a part of it.
And therefore the level of culpability
is more than Emonds and that's sufficient
for the death penalty.
A Justice Brennan,
uh,
joined by three other
members of the court dissent.
Uh,
they would treat the Tyson's just like
Inman and they would say that because of
the role that they've played because they
weren't the actual killers and because
they didn't intend to kill because they
were surprised by what their father and
the other person did that they should
not be subject to the death penalty.
But the court is now established
that major participation,
reckless disregard is going to be enough
to make someone eligible for the death
penalty and codefendant cases.
Um,
the court next turns to the question
of whether crimes that don't involve a
homicide are subject to the death penalty.
Uh,
very soon after the,
for the,
uh,
1976 cases,
the court looks at coker versus Georgia.
And the question presented there to the
Supreme Court is whether the sentence of
death for the rape of an adult woman
violates the eighth amendment's cruel and
unusual punishment clause.
It's important to note adult woman
because even after this court or the court
decided this case,
uh,
there remained a question about whether
or not a sexual abuse or rape of a child
might be eligible for the death penalty.
Uh,
but George's problem and arguing for
the death penalty for the crime of rape,
uh,
was that it was fairly well isolated,
after the Ferman decision had come down.
And his number of states adopted
new death penalty statutes.
Only three,
Georgia,
North Carolina and Louisiana,
uh,
provided the death penalty
for the crime of rape.
Uh,
but the North Carolina,
Louisiana statutes were both found to
be unconstitutional in 1976 and Woodson,
uh,
versus North Carolina and
Roberts versus Louisiana.
Uh,
so Georgia now has left as the only state,
uh,
that makes this provision.
So when the court now does this
examination of how many states have this
punishment,
uh,
Georgia finds itself all alone.
Uh,
the court looks at the last 50 years and
notices that are majority of the states
have not punished rape with the
death penalty in the last 50 years.
Uh,
in 1925,
18 states provided,
uh,
for the death penalty and as well as
the district of Columbia and the federal
government,
uh,
by 1971,
that number gone down just a bit,
16 states and the federal government.
But by the time cokers decided,
uh,
in 1977,
only Georgia.
So Georgia is one out of 50 states
that provides this punishment.
The court then looks to what if the jury's
in Georgia been doing with regard to
this and it finds that of the,
uh,
63 rape cases that have happened or
that had been tried capitally uh,
in Georgia since this statute was adopted,
uh,
only six times have juries
impose the death penalty.
So the court concludes
that it's infrequent.
That is only one state has it.
And even in the state that has it,
it's infrequently used a justice white,
uh,
writes the opinion and expresses the,
not only does the counting of the states
but expresses the abiding conviction
that the death penalty is
excessive for the crime of rape,
particularly since some people who
actually kill people don't get the death
pony.
What we're seeing here is the
court is roughly going to say,
uh,
that the death pony is limited to cases
and where life has taken the same day
that a coker was decided.
The Supreme Court just issued a little,
a one paragraph opinion in a case called
Everhart versus Georgia in which it
said that the death penalty cannot be
imposed for the crime of kidnapping where
there had not been a loss of life.
Uh,
and as we'll see,
the court is going to decide
and Kennedy versus Louisiana,
the even in the case of a child,
uh,
the death penalty cannot be imposed
where there is no loss of life.
Uh,
Brennan and Marshall in this case
say that the death ponies always
unconstitutional.
Uh,
so they join the majority of justice
white rights and they side with him.
But for different reason.
Uh,
Justice Powell says the death pony may
be constitutional for aggravated rape.
Uh,
and then just as Chief Justice Burger,
uh,
joined by Justice Rehnquist says
that rape is not disproportionate.
Uh,
and he looks at coker in particular.
in three years,
coker had raped three people.
He had killed one.
He had tried to kill
another and he had escaped.
If ever there is a person,
chief justice burger is saying for whom
the death penalty is appropriate for
this crime.
It's coker.
Uh,
he describes him as a,
or the chief justice describes coker as
a chronic rapist and a continuing threat
to society.
Uh,
but that's the descending opinion.
so the result of the case is that the
death penalty cannot be imposed in a rape
case where there's no loss of life.
Now we move to Kennedy versus Louisiana
in which the court took on the sort of
exception here.
Coker had been about an adult,
uh,
person,
Kennedy versus Louisiana
presents the question of a child.
Uh,
once again,
this is just as Anthony Kennedy,
uh,
is going to write the opinion
for the Supreme Court.
Uh,
very interesting.
what he says,
uh,
at the,
in prefacing his analysis
of the issue here,
that when the law punishable by death,
uh,
it risks its own sudden
descent into brutality,
uh,
transgressing the constitutional
commitment to decency and restraint.
He says the evolving standards of decency
counsel us to be most hesitant before
interpreting the eighth amendment in
a way that's going to extend the death
pony.
The court is limited in many ways and now
justice Kennedy is saying we should be
very hesitant to extend the death
pelly decency in its essence a presumes
respect for the individual
and this moderation and
restraint in the application
of capital punishment.
Sure.
Markable statement for a majority of
the Supreme Court he's writing for a
majority of the court,
uh,
in this opinion,
which,
uh,
shows some hesitancy certainly
to extend the death penalty and,
uh,
some concern that whenever the court
is dealing with the death penalty,
it is,
he says,
uh,
risks its own sudden
descent into brutality.
When we look at some of the other
death pony cases decided by the court,
we don't quite see that same concern.
Uh,
well the court does,
once again,
it looks at the states and it finds that
44 states have not made such a crime
punishable by death,
uh,
since 1964,
which is even back before affirming to
eight years before Ferman only Louisiana
has sends to anyone to
death for this offense.
Uh,
no one has been executed for a non
homicide crime since 1963 and only two
people,
uh,
both in the Louisiana,
we're under the death sentence,
uh,
at the time for the rape of a child.
So the court sees here that
with regard again to looking,
is there a consensus in the country
with regard to this punishment?
Death is extraordinary punishment.
This era vocable punishment,
uh,
for even a terrible crime.
And there's no question the crime in
this case and any case involving a child
and a sexual abuse of a child is a,
is a horrible crime.
Uh,
but does it,
uh,
is a cup ability,
the offender such that
death can be imposed.
And the court,
uh,
here says,
we're not going to have the death
penalty where there's not a loss of life.
Uh,
points out that retribution,
uh,
the difference between a
particularly deprived murder,
uh,
where the person is killed and
where the person is not killed,
uh,
is the distinction that
has to be made here.
Uh,
that deterrence,
uh,
actually this may cut against,
turns,
uh,
because Justice Kennedy sees
the risk of non reporting.
Of course,
the court was informed
by a number of briefs,
some of them for,
from advocates for children who pointed
out that most of the sexual assaults
that take place or not by strangers who
break into the child's bedroom in the
middle of the night.
Uh,
but by family members,
by teachers,
coaches,
priests,
ministers,
uh,
people that the,
the,
that the family knows.
And that if you know that that
person who's been abusing you,
uh,
might be subject to the death Poli,
it might be a reason,
uh,
for some children to not report the
crimes is this is not going to serve the
purpose.
Uh,
and also this gives the
perpetrator a motive.
Uh,
if,
if the perpetrator is going
to be subject to the death,
plenty to kill the victim.
Uh,
finally he adds this,
uh,
point,
special risk of wrongful execution,
uh,
that children will cause they're highly
susceptible to suggestive questioning,
uh,
are,
unlike are there to be at least sometimes
not that they're likely to give,
uh,
evidence that's not going to be accurate,
but that this is,
there's a risk of this happening and this
is what the court is concerned about.
And all of these cases are we worried
about a risk of the death penalty being
imposed in a case where it shouldn't be.
And particularly here in a case where
44 other states have decided not to have
the death penalty for this crime and
only two people had been sentenced.
So the court puts all that together,
uh,
and comes to the conclusion,
that the death penalty is
not appropriate in this case.